our ancestors crossed the great void
untold millennia ago pilgrims from a
dying world long since lost from
tumultuous beginnings their struggle
courage and fortitude gave birth to our
civilization for many centuries our
people prospered peace ruled our planet
and our understanding of the world
around us grew our scientists have long
speculated that ours was not the only
tribe to make this journey and establish
a new home on another world but their
searching has been met again and again
with silence until now the transmission
was weak and incomplete but in a
language not unlike our own
our anticipation rule what culture and
knowledge had our brothers developed
during the long centuries of our
separation a starship was prepared
ambassadors recruited but gradually the
meaning of the message became clear it
was a desperate call for help
galvanized by the revelation that we are
not alone our fleet has been equipped
and
we are ready to answer the call of our
brother
what shall we find
of course beyond the stars
[Music]